Ekko isn't just a cool name for a
superhero it also reflects how the
character and the series embrace the
past to forge a new future here's how
the ending of Ekko brings it all
together Ekko takes place directly after
the events of Hawkeye in that show Maya
Lopez learns from Clint Barton that
Kingpin anonymously hired him as Ronin
to assassinate her father and several
other members of the tracksuit Mafia
Maya then leaves kingpin's organization
and confronts her former friend Kazi
Kazmir killing him during the tracksuit
Mafia battle against Clint and Kate
Bishop Maya later ambushes Fisk and
shoots him seemingly putting an end to
New York City's greatest gangster when
Ekko picks up Maya returns to her
hometown of tamaha Oklahoma to take over
fisk's operations there she locks horns
with her Uncle Henry who like Maya's
father was involved with kingpin's
organization against his will after
attracting unwanted attention from the
kingpin's henchmen Maya discovers that
Fisk is Al liive and he offers her a
chance to return to New York and resume
operations as his Queen pit
you want an
Empire you'll have it all the while Maya
is also having recurring visions of her
ancestors including the first Chaka
woman chafa as well as tuo a Chaka
Warrior from the 1800s she's also
confronting her strained relationships
with her family members including her
cousin Bonnie whom she avoided contact
with following her father's death and
her grandmother Chola whose anger
towards Maya's father left them
estranged Maya learns the truth about
her Visions from Chola realizing that
her ancestors are contacting her during
critical moments she later confronts
Kingpin in his hotel room and nearly
accepts his offer to kill him calling
back to his own experience of killing
his father to free himself from an
abusive household Maya refuses most of
the finale centers onto maha's Chakan
Nation powow a festival celebrating
their ancestry the tracksuit Mafia
arrive in search of Maya forcing Henry
and Maya's cousin biscuits to hold them
off wearing a costume given to her by
Chola Maya gets cornered by Kingpin and
his henchmen who have taken Chola and
Bonnie hostage Kingpin threatens to kill
them so that he's the only family Maya
has left but Maya uses her ancestral
powers for the first time to not only
fight off fisk's goons but to empower
Chola and Bonnie to fight alongside her
finally Maya takes control of fisk's
mind sending him back to pivotal moments
in his life including the moment before
he decided to kill his father she
encourages him to let go of his pain
Fisk terrified of Maya's powers and
perhaps his own memories abandons his
plan and escapes with his remaining
henchmen before Maya leaves to Maha she
visits her family at a barbecue and is
warmly welcomed all of them now free
from kingpin's control Ekko involves
Maya completing her transformation from
villain to superhero characters such as
Wanda maximoff and Loki have made the
transition from villain to hero and
occasionally back putting Maya in Good
Company among the Marvel Cinematic
universe's roster of evildoers turned
good guys
again fosta when Maya is introduced in
Hawkeye she's relentlessly chasing down
Ronin for killing her father targeting
Kate bishop and later Clint Martin
audiences can still empathize with Maya
during this villain Arc though
especially after flashback sequences
show her father encouraging her to adapt
to a world that won't accept her when
Fisk turns up alive in Echo Maya must
choose between her family and her
ambition it raises the question why does
Maya choose to be a hero rather than the
queen pin the answers lie in the
flashback sequences depicting Maya's
history working for Kingpin where she
interprets his affection for her as
paternal it's actually strategic Fisk is
no stranger to using cruel manipulative
tactics against those close to him case
in point in episode four of Ekko he
brings Maya her favorite cookies to
entice her into listening to him the
only difference is this time around Maya
is too wise to trust Fisk after all she
didn't pour out an expensive bottle of
wine for no reason they came highly
recommend it Hawkeye only briefly
examines Maya's history with Wilson Fisk
revealing that her father William was
fisk's partner in operating the
tracksuit Mafia Fisk took on the role of
an uncle figure in Maya's life this is
fleshed out much further through
flashback sequences in Echo in one
important flashback in episode 4 Fisk is
surprised when a young mayia joins him
in assaulting a rude ice cream vendor
this is the start of Maya's
transformation into one of fisk's
closest commanders this establishes that
Kingpin saw something in Maya early on
that made her a valuable asset to his
criminal Empire he never had to lure her
into his world of corruption she was a
willing participant even the act of Fisk
assaulting the vendor proves that his
love for Maya is genuine though still as
toxic as any of fisk's other
relationships no more is this apparent
as in fisk's relationship to American
Sign Language or ASL the only way for
him in Maya to communicate while every
other character in Ekko is fluent in ASL
Fisk is not which Maya calls him out on
as evidence that he doesn't truly care
about her comic Basics interpreted this
as an example of fisk's shortcomings as
a character writing Kingpin was likely
incapable of truly bonding with people
and since Maya saw him as some kind of
heroic personality when she was little
Kingpin liked it family is a major theme
in eeko with one of the very first
scenes depicting the traumatic car crash
that tore Maya's family apart when Maya
returns to Taha tensions Run High
between her and her relatives there's
her Uncle Henry who is still involved in
fisk's organization her grandmother
Chola who turned her back on Maya and
her father years ago and Bonnie Maya's
closest childhood friend who she's
desperate to keep away from the criminal
World along the way Maya is plagued with
visions of her ancestors she eventually
Embraces them and is rewarded with
superpowers Ekko shows that Maya is
stronger both literally and figuratively
when she accepts her family her past and
her flaws she tries to pass this on to
Kingpin during their final fight forcing
him to relive his most painful memories
when Maya encourages Fisk to let go of
his pain Fisk instead runs away
appearing more like a frightened child
than an intimidating Crim Lord
what did you do the strength of families
has been a part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe throughout its many phases from
the very first Thor movie to 202's
eternals while tragedy and Trauma might
make many people run away from the ones
they love the most Ekko shows that Maya
is her best self when she's fighting to
protect them fans eager to see Maya
Lopez come into her own as a superhero
and Ekko had to wait a bit it takes all
five episodes for the character to
embrace her heroic side it's not until
her conversation with Chola in episode 4
that Maya learns that her powers come
from her ancestors calling to her
Generations are
echoing reaching
out to
us at a time
[Music]
when some critics felt the explanations
for Maya's superhero abilities were
underdeveloped with the Ringo writing
Lopez's superpowers manifest late in the
season but are never really explained or
demonstrated clearly there are many
different powers showcased among the
Lopez women from her mother's ability to
heal to Maya's ability to force others
to experience Visions as she does with
Kingpin ultimately it appears that
Maya's superpowers are gifts given to
her by her ancestors while the exact
details of what she can do remain
unclear the important distinction is
that Maya is being aided along her
journey by the strong choca women who
came before her the main lesson from
Maya story is that she is stronger when
she Embraces that she's living as a
result of her family's past not in spite
of it in the series Maya superpowers are
rooted in Chaka mythology with her
oldest ancestor chafa becoming a heroic
figure of the Chaka creation myth many
aspects of Chaka mythology play an
integral role in shaping Maya's Powers
this comes as a huge shift for those
familiar with the character from Marvel
Comics Maya first appeared in 1999 sent
by Kingpin to antagonize Daredevil the
two adversaries eventually became
romantically entangled Maya's
connections to Kingpin in the comics are
similar to those in the series however
one massive change comes with her powers
in the comics Maya has photographic
reflexes allowing her to copy her
opponent's movements this is
coincidentally a similar ability to
Taskmaster who appeared as an antagonist
in 2021s Black Widow it's not the first
time Marvel has done this with their
characters as they made similar changes
to commala Khan in the 2022 series Miss
Marvel her abilities were also
reinterpreted to fit her cultural backgr
ground and ancestral history Echo
director and executive producer Sydney
Freeland explained the changes an
attempt to be more representative of
Chaka history Freeland told Variety in
2023 her power in the comic books is
kind of lame representation was
extremely important to myself and to
everyone on the crew Ekko is one of
Marvel's more ambitious projects despite
also being its shortest at only five
episodes as the show star alaa Cox told
collider the emotional scenes with
Vincent denafo towards the end were
challenging as she put it I remember
looking on the call sheet for the next
day and seeing how it was such an
intense emotional scene and I said oh
crap naturally though she also hoped the
show left fans wanting more stating we
never know where Maya is going to go
next so I think that they'll all be
curious about that the supporting actors
in Ekko also felt somewhat intimidated
by the project also speaking to collider
Dey Jacobs who plays Bonnie singled out
the finale's poow as a daunting setpiece
saying it was done so beautifully by our
director Sydney freland who was just
like a rockar in all of it and I don't
think that we could have brought it home
with anyone else Vincent denafo also
described to Entertainment Weekly how
the final scene of Kingpin sets up a
promising future for his character when
he said there are so many places to go
with this character it's crazy Denario
also feels optimistic about his return
in Daredevil born again he continued the
reception of Ekko so far is helping
everybody understand that this is a
really good tone for Daredevil 2o I
think Born Again is heading in that
direction in a major way now there are
plenty of other firsts with Ekko and one
of them has to do with branding the show
is designated as a Marvel Spotlight
which is meant to signify that a certain
show or movie can be watched as a
standalone project even if you're not
familiar with the rest of the MCU
because Ekko is the first to be labeled
as such its success will likely
determine Marvel's ambition in moving
forward with future Marvel Spotlight
projects the show success unfortunately
may also determine Maya Lopez's future
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe At
Large unlike other Marvel series Echo
does not end with confirmation that Maya
Lopez will return and considering the
character's current irrelevance to the
larger Multiverse Saga of phases 4- 6
she might just remain a supporting cast
member in future projects one of those
may be Daredevil Born Again In which
Charlie Cox and Vincent denafo will both
be appearing there's certainly a lot of
stories to be told involving Maya Lopez
if her comic book history is any
indication at one point the character
Dawns the mantle of ronin and at another
time she becomes a host for the Phoenix
Force Maya was also nearly included in
in the moonnight series as a potential
love interest for Oscar Isaac's Mark
Spectre so it's possible that those two
characters could cross paths at some
point of course it wouldn't be a Marvel
Cinematic Universe installment without a
hint as to what's coming up in a
mid-credit scene for the final episode
of Ekko Vincent denpro Kingpin sits on
his private jet waiting to take off and
return to New York his attention is
caught by a news program on the plane TV
in which New York City's mayoral
election is being discussed a bare
knuckled brawler would do well in this
race and Outsider somebody who is not
afraid to take on the establishment the
look on fisk's Face seems to indicate
that he intends to join the campaign and
knowing how powerful he is in New York
City he'll likely win this could set the
stage for fisk's role in Daredevil Born
Again despite reports of creative
overhauls in recent months denafo
confirmed on Twitter the changes are all
positive telling variety frankly I'd be
worried if we were settling for Less
this would make Daredevil Born Again an
adaptation of an integral Kingpin
storyline from Marvel Comics in which
Wilson Fisk becomes the mayor of New
York City and furthers his plans to
resurrect his dead wife Vanessa fisk's
new position could also find him at odds
with other NYC based superheroes such as
Spider-Man doctor strange and Kate
Bishop yet again Ekko is certainly one
of the more exciting projects in the
Marvel Cinematic universe's recent
output whether it's because of the focus
on a deaf disabled indigenous character
or its depiction of violence more akin
to the Beloved Netflix shows it
certainly feels like a step forward the
biggest step though is the involvement
of the Chaka Nation during the show's
development as director Sydney Freeland
described a deadline the chock to were
so crucial because they had their own
written histories or oral histories and
cultures and traditions that were drawn
from and it really was a collaboration
between myself our production and the
chocks that didn't go unappreciated by
Marvel right before the credits roll on
echko a title card specifically thanks
the choon nation of Oklahoma for their
consultations on the project the
collaboration didn't stop at the
development stage either Marvel has
included a Chaka language dub of Eko on
streaming services and members of the
Chakan Nation went into detail regarding
their work with Marvel on the nation's
official website it's quite possible
that we could see more Native American
Marvel characters appear on screen soon
like Wyatt Wingfoot or
Warpath